lady and gentleman Monday I want to just
give a shout-out to our Veterans
Memorial Day somebody said to me happy
Memorial Day and it's not a happy day
for a lot of people really quickly it is
a day that honors the 1 million plus men
and women who gave their lives in
service so this is a very important day
very sad day for the families of people
who've made the ultimate sacrifice this
country again we fight for those ideals
of life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness which was a new idea when it
came about and still is most countries
are are basically structured around
authority and you know hierarchy and and
god-given you know status not so in this
country all men are created equal
at least that's the idea that we reach
for so the robbing Captain America
that's right thank you
we brought the biggest goddamn message
we could find him right let my pipe down
before sex light me down I'm gonna bring
in I'm bringing a man mr. Olympia and
you know I read it you know you makes
you look like a string bean writing a
lot brandy bright you look like you have
some horrible virus mixes that's exactly
right and I'm going to flash eating
button and I want everybody know that
but what through this if you will allow
I'm going to take my shirt off and stand
next to you and I'm going to do some and
you're going to pose and I'd like to I'd
like to match your poses I don't want to
put you on the spot so let's even get
weird the entire show Brian is going to
be talking about your muscle haven't
acknowledged all having you I don't your
girls here if you want to slap in well
we hung and we hung in Denver and had a
blast
Stevie blue-eyes considers you his best
friend and and but but you were big then
and I swear to God you've gotten bigger
in two weeks bulking bro he's balking
right now well you could you go into
your area as a prep wendell ice at no
june-june dan talking yeah to the
Olympians everyday hamburg yeah so
you're gearing up here yeah big so
you're in pre-season right now it's like
FTAs with hamburgers he's an OG a
hamburger and by the way he's you you
are i watch this video of a thin very
muscular black man well I shouldn't say
black because you have more about corn
boys and what a gold car mount locust
kind of like somebody been eating too
many caramels you know I'm saying let's
say mocha is that what he today um
either way he 5 9 and he windmill
Donnelly's he time he saw the brown
angel windmill though he
in Mill dunked at five nine now you went
to UC Denver sir D you
but those what we say on the street we
call them hops
we've got filled hot one nothing will is
will was gonna find a good bill where
you won't you'd say well I wrote a song
I'm not gonna sing it but this is what I
was doing in the in the shower this is
not even further on I was going I swear
to God I think shower I'm thinking about
you and I guess what I gotta go let
naked dripping wet yeah get ready
literally I was like Phil he he's
treating rippling mound of beef cake
every time he's he he's around makes me
feel so friggin safe safe he's brown
with C blue eyes want to squeeze his
buys and tries got symmetry and style
don't get me started on entire that's as
far as I run has a rock-hard boner right
now this is so of you exercises you
better [ __ ] recognize there's one
King don't even try he'll make you
[ __ ] cry just like he did to my man
cow what the crime is black body
building did you witness it is anyway um
no [ __ ] that that's literally what I was
doing in the shower I did a little
jingle came to me are you so much lather
did you have like a lot only clean my
nether regions are you still at a
Armbrust yeah that Jim still a pump in
and yeah yeah we're killing I missed
that placement yeah it's like to be it's
like the Gold's Gym of yeah Denver
basically my Mecca yeah yeah now when
you go in there because there it's got
to be interesting for you to deal with
the energy that comes with being mr.
Olympia soon to be number seven
what do you how do you deal with that in
the gym two guys leave you alone for the
most part yeah they leave me alone for
the most part but you know you do get
those newbies that come in or or fans
from abroad that have to take a holiday
and say hey I'm going to go kind of like
how they do at Gold's Venice yeah you
know people do a holiday here and then
they'll come to Denver and say I want to
go see where Phil he trains and yeah
sometimes they wait outside hoping that
I show up and then you show up and you
kind of have to kindly tell them you
better get me right when I'm walking in
yeah right when I'm leave this is where
I work this is where I work you see
run the rock posted a thing because he
was at Gold's all the time and people
come up to him and bother and he was
like hey listen I try and be a dick but
if I my headphones in and you see me in
the middle of a workout please don't ask
for a picture or video yeah that's like
berries don't ya absolutely I mean
that's a total distraction and what
people don't realize and that's your off
season - yeah but even then I mean I'm
still working and could you imagine
always having someone do that creepy
[ __ ] with the with the camera but the
camera phone they forget that you're
holding heavy weight yeah
and that's and that's the biggest
problem is that here you are trying to
focus and imagine doing like a 500 pound
squad or something like that and
someone's here snap snap or this that or
someone doing the corner face selfie on
you and you can get injured so or if
your technique so who knows if these
often get the lifting wars I'm mister
olimpio
how about the rounded back yeah hey
don't talk to him like dude head
movement looks like some 16 year old in
his basement like god dammit man so
that's that's the more difficult part
and we're finding more with and I hate
to say it but with the Millennials yeah
where they ever is that they'll be in
there flex in with their shirt half up
and this net and you're like hey man
you're in front of the dumbbell rec
doing this you got to show some better
gym etiquette and stuff like that so
fortunately enough at Armbrust and
you've seen it we have more middle-aged
guys that have been around late long
enough to kind of like slap these young
kids up and say hey look that's not how
we get it done let's be respectful
because it's a pretty hardcore gym but
yet is clean right and that's what we
try to keep their butt and other gyms
abroad like when we my girl and I we go
train
it can become a freakin problem so kind
of have to call the gym ahead of time to
let them know you're coming in and then
just say nicely hey I'm in here if you
want your staff because staff will do it
- oh yeah you know our staff will do it
- so you got to let them know ahead of
time I'm coming in we're going to Train
afterwards hey we can get a group shot
or whatever for like 5-10 minutes that's
it that's how long when you stay trained
I got how long is the training session
for you 90 minutes on average 90-minute
yeah we're hitting it we're hitting
individual muscle groups for sure when
you but when you go abroad like
bodybuilding is so much
don't get me wrong it's pretty big here
but abroad if you're like Tom Cruise on
that Germany and be like all our summer
like you're like you just mentioned
earlier like how you're going to
Australia yeah I remember spending an
entire month there doing a whole tour
all the way from the bottom all the way
up to Darwin near the damn equator and
back up taking Australia it's I mean you
know it's big enough you know and as far
as the bodybuilding scene it does Trump
the US and some in some areas just for
body the wines that you think I don't
know but I do know this that at one
point in time sourcing agar was down
there quite a bit you know he did a lot
of seminar down there a lot of those
photos that you see of him back in the
pumping iron days yeah the black and
white have said you know that's over in
Coogee Beach is it really an over at the
Opera House but they never had like
Australia they've never had like a big
time not being like no Ben no never
you think the Olympia would do it like
in turn a stuff like Olympia Germany
Olympia UK so because they keep it in
Vegas that so they'll Orleans for God's
so before that 99 it was in other cities
and countries when it originated we're
talking like over 50 years ago the
Olympia was started in you know gosh
it'd be in Pretoria South Africa where
pumping iron was filmed um different
parts of Germany Atlanta Georgia I mean
he would jump around kind of like the
Olympics on me I don't go that land and
yeah but it was in different areas and
then finally in 99 they decided to have
it at the Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas and
they just kept it there yeah
and to be honest I mean I see the point
because it's easier to have everybody
fly to Vegas then you're not going to
get any Americans that you know there's
not enough Americans I even use a
passport let alone you know know how to
get around in Europe and Asia so it's
just so big - I feel like you guys to do
yeah that's a bigger venue if you did in
Germany or something yeah I think it has
the infrastructure for that yeah I
believe so too and we're talking about
you know the e-commerce part you know
the commerce part about it is huge
tons of supplement companies you know
equipment companies you name it you know
all have no problem finding the states
to get you know more business made in
Expos but I do agree that there should
be
more shows outside the US that are
larger and that's why the Olympia brand
has decided to do like an amateur
contest in different parts of the world
from Russia to Germany and now starting
to do pro shows in those areas too and
Arnold Schwarzenegger has his Arnold
Schwarzenegger classic in Brazil
Australia undersell that Marshall Ohio
right guard in Ohio and now he has it in
Hong Kong as well as gosh I'm and yes
South Africa Australia Hong Kong
Barcelona and got real he's killed so
he's so he's doing that so now the
Olympia is realizing like hey look
bodybuilding is in over 150 countries
there's different amateur Olympia
contest among pro shows they're
representing that brand to in Kuwait and
also in other parts of the country other
parts of the world so it's growing of
course for me I'd love to participate
but I'd like the cries mother you go up
a little bit more yeah for me to do that
use do you get a different kind of
recognition when you go across these and
do here yeah I mean you know living in
Denver it's it's like hey do you play
for the Broncos or something it's like
and then some people are starting to
recognize the swoll ascend FL player I
know and I always say that [ __ ] I'm
running back [ __ ]
how about ya play running back Yeah
right I see no running back never felt
they don't look like hell no so outside
of Denver you know when I come in LA and
stuff yeah people recognize me in this
net but when I go abroad yeah it's bad
when you hear T you know all that what
you win pumping iron - kima have you
seen that be no I saw generation iron
yeah yeah Jess I'm sorry yeah well
alright yeah dude there's a scene in
that movie where I last the horse I've
ever lied about a night title I know it
anything I say what it is go ahead how
many if I'm right when he's on horseback
homeboys on the horse all brand he's all
finally feeling good no injuries ah
hello falls off oh my god [ __ ] it I quit
you we heard out I was laughing so hard
was too and it was terrible because he
even said he even said I think writer
this year no I haven't had any injuries
a lot of times you get injured not
lifting you doing other dumps often hey
hey any self so itself cuz you got so
much muscle he was able to really be
doctor deck and with
that sucked was that like that was not
supposed to be in the film oh well yeah
and you know of course the directors
gonna say no no it's not going to be in
there don't worry well which I don't
yeah so I would have put it in our
friends with branch and I felt horrible
because I remember watching that the
premiere and I'm like oh man branch is
gonna kill this run was branch upset
well yeah because I mean you know it was
kind of embarrassing but people don't
realize the backstory from it
oh they'll handle the sound boom spook
the down whorls
and hold their asses good leave them
alone and you know a horse do like this
oh yeah there's no animal to fight yeah
so much they don't horse they spill
hello Gary
oh yeah what does oh my my oh yeah
because remember they had to get that
boom mic position a certain way while
he's on it and they didn't educated the
hell out of the dam and that thing looks
a boss yeah there goes his chances yeah
dude yeah is a key dance
yeah so that was unfortunate because it
wasn't like what you saw in the movie
like oh he gets on there and the horses
yeah I mean that would be funny I was
dying I met my cousin yeah I'm sure he's
a great guy and I just felt but it was
just so it was so it was important part
of the movie actually yeah and you know
to his credit you know he got hurt but
he didn't look bad it was just no just
one of them it was just one of those it
look bad but it wasn't it's not like we
charged you mr. Limpy I being right yeah
I was able hello that kick him out of
the I think no it'll help me yeah that
didn't help them I mean he had torn ACL
the big was prior to that how about this
on horses so my wife rides a lot okay so
she's out in West Lake and she's riding
with your eyes and her horse got this
these competes on this horse real
beautiful expensive beautiful and this
horse starts getting Melilla well kick
him in heaven and said what the [ __ ] is
going on that and wouldn't and it kept
backing up and there was this pile of
wood it's like well I don't understand
what's going on what does he cease
looking around cuz they'll spook at his
plastic bag or something or maybe
nothing couldn't figure out and the guy
who had been to one of the groom's just
this guide in release begins I will just
new horses he goes off a lot of lives
later this is hard
moving the wood farm get too sick and a
giant rattlesnake was in the wood and
snakes are very afraid I mean a horse a
very fresh snake who and that thing and
any and he knew that the horse and he
smelled or be sent and that a snake was
bucking in the hope well Wow race race
rust is a boom mic yeah well we might
look like a those guys are lucky that
they didn't get their ass kicked by
brand how mad he was so he had to be
pissed I mean I didn't put it like this
I don't care I'll talk to him about it
really went out of his talk to him was
that was that Generation X was out there
yeah what Jen shot was a lot of it uh
script that you would you know I'm
saying like did with the story's real
unfortunately I think their goal was to
get like more of a docudrama out of it
than how it was initially presented it
was presented to us at least to me as
documentary and then you know I would
ask questions like so what are you're
interviewing me but what did the other
guys say now of course this is where
reality shows are you know predicated
it's really our story's narrative right
so I thought that the guys that were
involved if they were being honest about
who they are and what they do would be
good enough but they had to embellish
certain aspects of it and you know as a
viewer like when I saw the premiere I
thought well I guess they kind of have
to change the narrative up just to make
it entertaining yeah but unfortunately
for me of course they didn't go into my
so-called character deep enough to show
to illustrate like how I became champion
what does it take to maintain that it
was more like Phil Heath has everything
going for himself Kai green lives in the
[ __ ] yeah and he eats one meal a day
and this and that yes but he taught me
poses in the subway to make money and
he's dead broke Lee thereby what is is
over it's so [ __ ] stupid because when
I was second in the world I was still
making you know over half a million
dollars living had two homes driving
Bentley all of the [ __ ] right shoes
Angeles oh all right I just think that
he had more than one residence yeah and
you know they chose to show that so he's
got easy money oh hell yeah the guy's
made over make it big again
yeah well I'm talking about when I was
second-best I'm saying I was making just
in contests and guess poses and stuff
like that over half a million right
excluding endorsements others I think if
you're doing little idle fun if you're
number one you're number one yeah don't
you think you're going to go in a higher
tax bracket yeah absolutely so how does
that work so that I was more confused
with how the viewer got so [ __ ]
stupid in the thinking like that's his
real life you find you find yourself
like he's this underdog I thought I knew
all right let me ask you this one when
when that guy goes to that expert who
can tell you whether you're ready or not
I think he's been in jail for a while or
something oh um longer Martinez when I
and he was flexing and the guy it was
really wow that might have been true
because I saw the guy that way true yeah
you can see the guy were through and he
was like trying to be cool and he goes
he doesn't I just don't think you're
ready oh that's our head judge Steve
Weinberg he's awesome and he's like
straight New Yorker
Stowe's told it to you like it is yeah
we'll go in your face and be like I've
seen a million times people go to his
gym over in Long Island and ask for his
critique and that's what Victor was
doing okay and what you saw right there
was totally real
Steve was looking at my my it hurt him
to say yeah and Steve's knowing Victor
for forever throughout this majority of
is pretty much all of his career last
thing you want to say is now you're not
ready but he doesn't want make you look
like a fool and it hurts the sport
itself if you're ready get up there yeah
it's like in boxing or MMA you know if
you know the guy is fresh off the couch
is gonna get his ass kicked not really
that yeah you don't want to see that
that's just bad for everybody so Steve
um yeah he's one of those guys like if I
like I'm gonna do an appearance for him
next weekend actually this Saturday and
if I'm 18 weeks out from the Olympia and
I say hey how am I looking
I better be prepared for that same
critique that he gave Victor pretty
harshly yeah because that's the same guy
that's going to be judging you on stage
and well he look at you and say
something like your delts need more
development you got to bring your biceps
up close oh for sure and look I tell you
that you're not going to get it in time
damn dang I mean it's not even a hater
doing it honest that's the hardest part
about mr. Lippe
no I mean he may say he does is he mr.
Olympia doesn't matter to shut your
mouth because he's animal yeah
he's seen during eights of course he's
seen Ronnie Coleman Lee Haney he's seen
these guys so it's like you you were
asking for adjudication and you better
look like me have a no fight experience
going out to bas Rutten and saying did I
throw this punch correctly and he's like
hell no you didn't the UFC's right now
the price slide yourself yeah the
opponent by sight
I dunno I was like yeah I'm not matter
what the [ __ ] no matter around house
yeah in there yeah anywhere so I'm good
legit yeah when I have heard Arnold talk
about this I've always I want to ask a
bodybuilder where he will focus on that
one muscle part like actually think it
bigger like it blows your mind I'll
connect he had you do I chitter and I
believe that when you are training that
that muscle group it's your job to focus
your mind into that area to stimulate
more growth right so it's just like
remember when you're a teenager and
you're trying to flex your pecs or
something like that yeah that takes mind
muscle connection I would do push-ups in
the bathroom before I went out to meet
the girl I wanted sex with I have my
shirt off and I to get a little pump
going it's very sad well you're
definitely trying to focus your mind and
I weigh like I got to get this chest
accoutrement tonight so it's no
different than this and I think it would
be somewhat synonymous to like when I'd
be playing basketball in college like
focusing on my form and technique you
know shooting a jump shot like you got
to know how that touch is that you're
focusing on every little aspect there is
and in bodybuilding is it's a cold sport
so people don't you know they just think
oh you just go in there and just do this
and it works so yeah no no we're trying
to you know involve more money muscle
connection to get those different fibers
you know working together I'm fine yeah
for you too because this you're going
for your 7th right yes you don't burst
up the records 10 8 8 yeah dangly handy
right yeah Lee Haney and Ronnie Coleman
boson 8 so that is it you have to do a
different approach every year or that
you just have to maintain that look that
it's gotten you the trophy already I
think just overall your your your body
is going to evolve you're just like
anyone's you know fighting style or
basketball play or whatever your body
essentially is going to get used to
certain stimuli so you have to figure
out in bodybuilding at least things grow
at different rates and time
so like let's say you know someone's
legs are always going to be big yeah
that means that maybe they have to make
sure their upper body catches up and
then once an upper body catches up maybe
the e needs to Train calves more or
something like that so for me
last year's emphasis was making sure my
leg development was on poor on par with
everybody else and it's not better so I
trained it twice a week now they're
they're much better that I have to make
sure that I'm still hitting on this hard
but now I got to train my calves harder
because my quads got too big yeah damn
so I see all the different things cosmic
rocks above
oh yeah just Minh yeah when I first
became in Olympia people are like wow
you look really really good I was like
oh thanks like what you do different I
said I stop training arms every week
they're like what I go my critique
always was that fill his arms
overpowered his physique like it
overpowers his delts in his chest so I'm
thinking okay well if I train my delts
in chest twice a week and then train my
arms maybe once every two three weeks
even a little even it out and people say
why would you no one wants it like not
train arms it's like yeah I don't not
want to but in this game you're trying
to you know make sure everything is
balanced are you are you are you
self-conscious about anything like we
look in the mayor Oh every day really
guys right everyday men out of shape now
even though you're soulless lug yep
really day you like damn yeah man that
every or just not as big or or wow like
I you know like my girl now we're here
on vacation and stuff just hanging out
why only three times today this is
[ __ ] done today yeah you're thinking
absolutely yeah but you know you're
thinking I got seven more you know how
many calorie meals a day how many
calories over 5,000 so how am I gonna do
that when I'm on vacation
yeah well we can do that yeah we can do
that are you one meal okay so when so
right now you can basically eat whatever
you want cuz went before you go into
this strict training camp right now is
just you're getting anything you want
are you still I'm still practicing good
habits it's just that I'm practicing
what I preach you know two people in a
choir which is you know even five-six
good meals a day and they said to me I
was like you know lean clean meals I
mean I can still have you know protein
steak fit you know like steak fish
chicken
carbs whether it be white rice or brown
rice
different types of potatoes the only
difference is right now I'm able to have
like sushi or pasta or more sauces on
meals
what about dessert yeah so I can have
dessert like you know once a day and
that's that and that ain't bad right now
like I'm getting all that in and then if
I want to have a glass of wine or
whatever I can do that but seven come
next week there's none of that so next
week next week yeah so I want to sorry
that's when the shred it down officially
starts next week fighting camp starts
next week yeah so how far out are you in
September yes the September in
mid-september so we're like 16 weeks so
you got you got a strict 16 weeks and
when do you guys go keto completely
toward the end and not necessarily
because so for my body type what we do
is carb cycling say keto be yeah because
I know fitness a lot of fitness
competitors want to really shut up they
just stick to literally a keto s bucket
yeah I think raise four for me that
doesn't work very well because of the
fact that you know to keep the roundness
in my muscle it needs a larger glycogen
storage so I got it in just a lot of
cars I've never heard of bodybuilders
doing yeah because they're fattening out
as they get [ __ ] fat and then they
realize oh [ __ ] like I got to rip up for
this contest and they have to switch and
sometimes guys have had metabolic damage
because of them you know dieting like
fat diet style yeah and the keto diet
helps them you know restore like they're
you know adrenal glands and also
something to do like an adrenal glands
beforehand and then we'll do this keto
die to get their metabolism going so
then they can eat more of healthy foods
but for me I try to stay within 25
pounds of striking distance throughout
the year so I don't have to kill myself
on the cardio and on the double oh no no
no you know because who wants to live
like that especially during the middle
of summer
you know that's brutal because you get
hot yeah I mean that's why I mean it's
I'm in Denver man like it's you know
high altitude is dry it can be miserable
you know if you treat your body like
that and you have a whole team say have
a dietician shut everything uh well my
chef my girl you know she's she's you
know really sold here take all your
meals yeah I'm hope thank you she's in
shape dude here's the part time so
here's the Vatican so here's the best
part
about it you [ __ ] so sorry my girls
you'll hit up as we just came in with a
troll I know he's got hair on our backs
at least you make all feel great girl I
got a big wart on her face I get she
took the mean piece of chicken baby
thinkin she's a really handsome young
man and the thing about her just shows
up as a toilet for fabrics are at meals
though man
she made it my bear it looks like they
ugly-ass character from 300 yeah just
shield a get outta those artists taken
under the ropes or not barnacles
everybody's growth so she's in charge of
cooking so what you'll do is you'll get
the will get the tax measure or email
from my trainer honey Rambabu kind of do
the online console phone console and
she'll have the whole diet
she'll prepare all the meals and then
the times and everything and then you
know I'll eat them and honestly in
between that time have my thought
massage therapy once or twice a week D
tissue you know we do the infrared sauna
therapy that I have a hyperbaric at the
house I do acupuncture chiropractic work
two to three times a week and do all
that [ __ ] because in in like a in a
fighters training camp you know tonight
cause for a good training camp you know
with with the training partners gym food
guide all this stuff let's say it costs
50 G's to get kicked about that well
just dependent it at a world-class okay
50 G's for you since you're taking out
16 weeks it could be a lot I mean we're
talking along an estimate well cannot be
dead-on I'll need your tax is definitely
is definitely over 50 grand because you
got a thing just in food alone I mean
you're wrong to think yeah you're
swimming just on me jin-hwan okay just
no not that much but I mean yeah I think
okay I could do the math real fast I
mean a massage therapy alone it's going
to be over 10 grand chiropractic a must
yeah and that's I have to do it because
because you get so balled up and yet
yeah you keep setting that massage so
you have massage you can you can add
another 10 on that 212 just in
chiropractic and acupuncture learning so
now you got food which is easily 5 grand
a month just on me just on me okay so
it's more than that so we probably spend
out at ENSO this so in Cairo ratso
so acupuncture and chiropractic
what does that guy keep going through
this be but I know that's 30 genes so
you got just that alone and then you
know you know trips to California to go
see my trainer to go work out with him
flying him outs come see me cuz you have
a trainer all the time doesn't know not
all the time let me work out he'll send
me workouts but he'll also get a man a
fee though yeah
so there you go and that fee is
definitely pretty damn high so I mean
you know we're looking at a six-figure
deal just to go into you know contests
that's gonna cost me 100 grand look like
you [ __ ] man and then but does your
trainer work with anyone else compete in
Olympia um yet well he used to he used
to were other club other guys but now he
focuses on myself also a couple others
in different categories oh boy he's not
working with competitors yeah not guys
I'm good not yeah no look like you're
not selling Kai workouts hell no no so
when you when you do much so the point
of the massage therapy is to get muscle
recovery kind of absolutely but you know
you have to keep in mind I go through
injuries just like anybody else so now
you got a you know decrease like to Casa
Vida you know work on the lymphatic
system all those things you know because
I'm doing cardiovascular work you know
45 minutes twice a day so in order to do
a lot of the layers go down there yes
I'll set you know all step mill normally
I thought you guys didn't do any card
here hell no I mean you got a zero Tony
oh yeah I thought you just because it
got in the way of putting on Vulcans no
so that's why you end up eating more
because you're realizing like to keep
you know positive nitrogen balance you
got to ingest more proteins you know
moderate carbs healthy fats to just to
keep that energy level and that muscle
glycogen stores up so you can still stay
full and the guys that want to do keto
yeah I mean it works but they actually
may be more depleted at the end yeah are
their muscles although they're they
could be a very massive person but their
body doesn't have any push because they
have lack of carbohydrates
right they don't have that three
dimensional muscle that I present on
stage so what you so when you're in
train competing how many times a day
seven seven seven
that's not eight times I'll be honest it
sounds exhausting yes hell yeah do you
love it or sometimes the eating part I
give you like I'm behind you guys yeah
you had a hell yeah you always fall the
the week the week of the show is the
worst because I'll be in Vegas she'll be
you know short-order cook like honey
could say hey cook this this and this
and then he'll take a look at me and say
scratch that [ __ ] we're doing this meal
instead Wow and then so she's got to
make that and then I have to eat with
now we're talking about water depletion
so now it's going toward the end of the
prep let your brains firing just fun to
you're ready to just kill I I hear how
fighters get I'm probably right there
like if you came into my room like hey
if it was going on and we had like a
burger and fries and [ __ ] I probably
could noticed yeah you're not making
water is what you're saying
yeah toward the end I mean I'm having
like okay so the Friday night is on um
you know for Jennifer yeah the
prejudging on Friday night so come
Thursday afternoon
maybe this those two waters for the day
what's this like [ __ ] eight
ounces each so on Friday maybe this much
that still left them necessary probably
six ounces and that's just a sip on
while you're eating so imagine eating
there's one thing of eating protein
right but try dry ass chicken or dry
state how there is or with them baked
potato
could you imagine with baked potato you
can put some butter on there no up no
siree man I don't know bro
[ __ ] in the flood damn it we are a
there's no butter you know no a dry
goddamn potato yeah you got to do this
stay could you imagine doing that eight
times in a day with no water not even
really hot in that film huh how long
have you been doing this science to [ __ ]
man I've been Proust in so far summer Bo
505 712 years so yeah 12 years pro well
in what to you is there have you guys
thought about this I talked about your
girls there like a end all right when he
gets 10 yeah there you go there's not
want to bring I want to break that
record
then wait then within 9 and 10 then be
out here with you [ __ ] and doing some
TV [ __ ] man like I hang at the Sears
trying to do the Arnold thing yeah like
playing around and all that yeah I'll
turn down if I have to I mean a face if
someone said hey you know you'd be
better off you know that I'm sitting at
270 right now because you need you had
245 fine I'll do it
if they need me to
thirty that's going to take some effort
but you know I'll get down to that it'd
probably be better on my joints and
stuff if they wanted me to run or do
something else I can rise to but I that
would be the goal I mean you know
currently right now you know I worked
you know very closely with the USO so I
do military appearances do a lot of that
cool stuff so I want to continue doing
that trying to get my you know self into
you know acting and whatnot but more
importantly just spreading the world of
health and fitness continuously
throughout the world but not just
through me being on stage yeah I want to
get involved in your school program
stuff like that be like that household
name by person you know my nicknames the
gift but I want to give myself to others
you know provide service it's great
being a champion but it's also greater
giving out service to others and try to
motivate them so when I'm not competing
anymore that's what I really want to
devote my time to do you I like the
youth are jumping into bodybuilding like
are they you know giving us a little bit
of a tough they it always be a
subculture yeah it always be a
subculture but I do think that with
these other categories you you will find
people that are interested in working
out because there's like a board short
what do they have like men's physique
you know they get board shorts and stuff
you have a French city yeah that's our
style be yeah yeah and then they have
classic physique which is a little bit
bigger but yet its height and weight
category yeah so that's I think that
category you're going to find those
people that you know really enjoy
working out still want to be somewhat
functional outside of just competing but
I do realize that those people that go
into that particular division just over
time will outgrow their division yeah
yeah because you get a kid that's 18
years old he's competing in this
division that division is going to max
he's going to max that out and he's
going to have to do open-class
bodybuilding yeah it's just over time so
I told those guys look I would have the
gameplan of doing those categories
whether it be men's physique the board
shorts and then doing the classic and
then saying look I want to be mr.
Olympia and that's only an open class
bodybuilding and it's the biggest prize
you know we make over $400,000 at the
mr. Olympia contest whereas they get a
olfaction of that it's not to say that
they don't work hard it's just that that
the mr. Olympia prize has the largest
lineage you know it's a it's the top of
it's the top of it a little bit to
everybody but let me ask one of these
that I've heard and I've read is that a
lot of like what we know about nutrition
mm-hmm actually came out of the
bodybuilding subculture like they so
yeah like like Joe Weider had been
talking about a lot of the stuff that
people are talking about now like low
carb or just you know good CaRMS way
back when and those muscle on Fitness
education yeah because they had to see a
day you guys you know think about it
means through competitive sport I mean
we're the guinea pigs right so whatever
you we're trying to go for a desire look
no different than that other person
wanting to go you know there's reading
the magazine that says gosh you know I
got this beard that I just want to get
shredded ass yeah well we're the ones
that know how to get that done we're the
ones that know how to get that extra
inch on your biceps your triceps your
job that's our drill FL they're not not
owns a colony my biceps good not right
they just want no be just more function
right so so for those guys and girls
that want to get you know you see more
girls one you know to get involved
because they want to not go the ass
injection route you know like they
actually want to say okay I can be
strong I can do back squats and this is
gonna be a B so girls to build that ass
let's be real how hard is it to build a
[ __ ] there's a girl that white girl the
flat ass is there ain't no Phil Heath
program you can do to get a big white
ass no they've mean the only the ones
that I've seen have the greatest success
of those girls that participated in high
school athletics I think which is great
because when you look at the female side
of things girls I wanted you like bikini
competitions fitness and like that as
those girls those those girls a dramatic
those girls yeah the same probably
always had like some genetic potential
some maybe some greater than others yes
but I think cuz I can I can see a woman
walking toward me right standing I got
jealous I know she's got an ass our hand
roll through the pop would pays on
Instagram let you know if you have
potential
yeah I'm right with you on that my
brother but but I can see a lot of times
I can see a woman the way she walks
toward I can see you're a body type I
know guy now on do almost love
Danzig listen Tatiana popular page I see
what you're working with
I don't feel heat I know fell yeah with
my 3 easy step program you know bla that
I am gonna take my workshop if the
person works out meet at Hotel hotel
that's it
yeah that's it Bryan Callen he some
living room school go to God before I
cry on a corner naked
I know you see there Sophie in the hotel
mirror that's it was icon by a great
time there are crows rooms hey for but
woman's body bone that's that's the
tricky one well that's it's going to
take a unique type of girl same with
women's MMA like for a girl to get
punched in the face like what did your
dad do wrong in women's bodybuilding
it's a compete like what you'd run so
those girls I see any mice and girls oh
it's now been on this decline and kind
of been pushed out so now they have
success alright now you can all right
now you cross that girls there so yeah I
think they have women's bikini you have
women's fitness you have women's figure
and now you have a new category called
women's physique and that's when they're
more streamlining but there's these kind
of like a Cory Everson Rachel McLeish
like yeah they're ours today so more
catered that way not so much bulky no no
no so and it's the I tell you what we've
just seen a couple girls those are one
brezhnev a shinee man there's this one
girl that did look at new york pro yeah
she did the new york pros and the girls
like flawless bring her up
spring rubber eruption Shanique yeah I'm
giving her yep you got a lighter still
does she know so I want you should me I
want to see to everybody I want you to
speak to this too because one thing that
I noticed that women now it is it is it
is and it's kind of a healthy family at
the end I think women women are
competing in powerlifting women are
committing and CrossFit women are
getting getting bulk and big and slow
for a woman now is considered a greater
than that girl oh yeah Sheen even big
this girl's like like freaking falling I
just hit images gym this girl freaking
stupid it's like not even fair and I
hate to say that disrespect to legs and
the abilities of Oh
see ya bodybuilders
man her oh she's she's actually well put
together I mean yeah Brian I'm up for
you
let's just you light me up yeah but you
know they look I mean no light on me I
step right up look at that we go to hips
can't I see some regular pic that's it
that's a clip a judge girl look at that
though look at those legs
it's in credit isn't yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm waiting to line the ass huh yeah
it's not for you I I know but you know
you gotta try sometimes you got got a
poker you got to put your finger in the
cage a little bit poke the day and she
is really pretty
yeah well she's clearly an extreme I
mean girl get more out of sweep I mean a
little ones got what way at all I mean
Neal just dropped a of some lingo
somebody feeling we go to a bikini waxes
don't you say about it though right so
that's not bad right now so now I'm not
matter so that's where they're going
toward you know that type of like Wonder
Woman look instead of gently yeah I mean
I'm excited for that division for the
women because yeah for quite some time
you know they said woman's body go in
this business well there were kind of
girl who wanted to look like you with a
wig on pretty much there's four of them
he's gonna take unique girl to sign up
for that no but they're like this that's
just awesome it is yeah you're seeing
more and more of this are you seeing
like like CrossFit Games and girls are
looking really muscular
yeah with oblique now that just now
that's a question I have for you guys
what do you guys think of this because
you know Colorado yeah you know very fit
place a lot of CrossFit places there but
I'm I'm having a problem with seeing
these girls do CrossFit and have this
linebacker ass physique well first like
real life celebrations like I said I'll
have yeah or cuz here's my thing about
it is is this that when you look at
these girls in the CrossFit Games the
ones that are really first of all there
are a lot of anabolics involved that are
and so their bodies are changing the
body look you've got this crazy traps
you've got crazy but the you know
obliques and and abs are the crazy six
and different beast yeah I mean they're
beasts they just look their bodies are
literally completely changed and what's
interesting about that is that I don't
find it unattractive I actually like a
muscular woman right very much but it
wins and I think more and more men
do it's becoming more kind of like
that's becoming more of the feminine
ideal which i think is I celebrate and
it's all good but what's interesting
about it to me is that it's it's you're
a bodybuilder so you're the pinnacle of
that well I think everybody like people
in CrossFit want functional strength and
everything but guess what else they want
to look great that's why they work out
with a shirt off and they do look great
yeah I mean you go to across the
gustatory that's polish yeah hungry I've
seen and it's just interesting that
there's almost like this when I see
those girls who are competing and
they're killing themselves doing you
know amazing things but when they're
bringing in the anabolic because they
want to compete with the other girls
were doing animals and then they're
looking like that they're looking closer
and closer to physique and fitness
people and I always kind of go what do
you what are we really doing here is
really going on well the goal the
overall goal between men and women
should be three things you know you want
to train hard train smart have fun but
also you want to you know you want to
look good yeah
you want to feel awesome and you want
have the courage to be able to you know
conquer your goals I think overall you
know what we're seeing now is just a
heavy increase and people wanting to
look good and that's and that's great I
am strong and strength you know and now
we're seeing like you know thanks to the
Marvel brand you know in DC comic brand
you know you're starting to see these
women be very powerful on film and
superhero esque most guys got into
weightlifting because of you know a
Charles Atlas but then also because of
source nature a hero action star shirt
or whatever and for me I've always loved
seeing cartoonish style muscle right and
you know being able to take my body to
the next level is important and you know
overall be honest now I know once I'm
done competing how to eat right what
works for me I can have healthy eating
habits not just for myself of my
girlfriend sharee but also when we have
children one day be able to say look
like you know this is what candy does
this is what you know good foods do yeah
and really know how to go to a
supermarket and figure out what's what's
really organic and what isn't you know
like really understand like what food
does so much interested right it's
really all food these days I mean look
like you cannot look like a mr. Olympia
being a rock star
Eitan [ __ ] and drinking beers and
stuff it just not going to happen you
have to know everything there is that
that you put in your mouth like you have
to know like okay what type of steak do
I eat what type of potato you got red
potato sweet potato yellow potato [ __ ]
how many other ones they I mean tons
right other potatoes that you avoid
versus because so right now I'm
realizing like a baked potato right now
is okay but come during prep like a
sweet potato like yam soup it's going to
be better I hear that Wyatt that sounds
like anybody structure it's different on
the glycemic index and stuff like that
you think Marta breakdown yeah and you
know different vitamins and minerals you
know beta carotene this and that would
you let your son if you wanted to do it
commit to it no and I'm going to tell
you why because I'm going to say son you
see all those trophies are you okay are
you going to be alright
going against that because you're not
going to get yourself you're gonna get
your dad that's very good and that's not
that's something that I know and I'm I
know right now what it took to get there
I don't want that pressure for him if he
says dad but I just want to do it for
myself and I'm gonna say look they're
always going to compare you to your dad
this is because when I break that record
I am going to be the greatest of all
time so that's your goal that may mean
that that's about that may be a
motivating factor that but I look at
like dad I don't work diaphragm that's
okay so that's cool like yeah I love
Dale jr. right yeah but he's all telling
it you retired yeah after a long-ass
career and he's also ranked how many
times the number one that's true
absolutely right but I wasn't as good as
dad but little about anybody saying that
you're not competing you're not impeding
with yourself you're competing with
against your dad I think it that there's
a lot of wisdom in that like that's a
mountain yeah and unless he unless he
choose it how many own volition along no
snow but not like how many people win
the Daytona 500 probably over 50 right
different guys there's only been 13 mr.
Olympius but he has fill-ins genes in
the collateral not no judge expect to my
girl half so so he's not going to try no
no no now I'm not saying that but what
does he have to give up see there was a
time when you
all of us had to give up something to
get where we're at today is him giving
up maybe a college education him giving
up time with his friends him giving up
everything worth that trying to read our
battery now what nobody else has ever
done out now if he says that I'm willing
to give up you know candy friend time
with friends and family and this and
that too to go after that time a
discipline you got to cause I'm fine
it's not happy it's pretty odd in
traditional you know me I was introduced
to bodybuilding after I got my education
and I got you know well yeah I mean I
was already here yeah I have asked my
Asian one now if he were to do the same
thing maybe I'd say okay [ __ ] if you
were to come up to me at the age of 15
and I'm looking at him like damn like
this guy like look better than me at
that time then we have a different
conversation but as a parent and a
father who knows what it takes to get
here I'll be damned if he doesn't get
the college education I had if not
better I'll be damned if he isn't better
than me you know just in everything he
has to be so much more well-rounded in
other areas of Business and Finance and
all this other stuff before he decides
to just because let's be honest man like
back when I turned pro in 2005 you were
guaranteed you know a six-figure income
through endorsements a guy that turns
pro at the mr. USA this year in July
probably won't even get signed to
anything why is that oversaturate
oversaturation really is are more
thousand more supplement companies out
there that are all for themselves
instead of the athletes himself they're
just here to get rich quick you know
they're not here with the passion that
you know when we have like old-school
Bill Phillips Conley for metrics we
don't have the Joe leaders we don't have
those same owners anymore we have hey
you guys want to make some products
myself it's no different than making a
t-shirt line yeah you know so they don't
have the same passion of bringing in
athletes to help sponsor their product
and put money into the athlete who's
gonna say hey look this is this is you
know what he does to be a champion know
they're going to give them a freakin ten
twenty percent off coupon code to be a
freakin ambassador for their line while
they make millions of dollars and give
no freaking money to the
Ashley that's helping their ass out
everyday so i gifted nutritions gonna
sponsor your son [ __ ] no no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] robbed me Yeah right yo you're
not with them at all no dude can't tell
this dude yeah he got [ __ ] the guy who
did it with kind of s 'old a lot of
money what man I got to do a deposition
here pretty soon going against can't
talked about it Friday no but to put it
like this when people say trust nobody
sometimes they're telling you the truth
when it comes to money being it comes to
like them using with your likeness and
stuff you know I got into that with guys
that I thought were my friend how well
did you know eight nine years man you
know these are people that I thought you
met him in the business sorta yeah you
know and you know they they pitched me
like oh yeah this is going to be great
that's not the other but they had a
different agenda
you know them embezzling money and this
not never telling me you're dying we're
talking major money here we're talking
millions so it's like how do you and
uncle and I never and I never received
one penny from the company over two
years and you're hustling for that
husband's traveling I traveled over 300
thousand miles in one year just to go
get nothing
so that's gosh that's the part of the
business right that you do you were
focused on other things yeah I was
distracted of course you know you know
you're busy yeah and trying trying to be
the best in the world is all right so
that's where he hired them right so no I
wouldn't have my son work for them know
that company is not going to be around
and probably even when he's born you
know so the goal is to even on that part
of the industry the education the of
e-commerce business the business side so
I would now no one no one solo yeah
agent yeah taking offers maybe no no no
I've got any part of it right now no
because I have other things that I've
got going on right now that I think are
far more important like we were talking
about before me giving back and doing
other things those things would come out
probably towards the Olympia can't
really talk about it right now but a
goal but the goal is is to you know show
that in life you will have curve balls
thrown at you but are you going to stand
there in the batter's box and not take a
swing you know curve balls can be hit
and that's what I preach to everybody is
that
you know you got a try you know I you
know I tried to be a bodybuilder October
8 2002 you know and Here I am you know
Memorial Day about 2017 at 6:00 time mr.
Olympia you know I made effort doesn't
mean that I didn't have [ __ ] man before
I even turned pro I had 43 damn dollars
to my name man before I got signed to
Joe Weider I have 43 damn dollars to my
hand and that's not even someone I talk
about because it's like really
everybody's got a [ __ ] story but yeah
I mean I would have I hate this [ __ ] on
your stories rock at seven he had seven
bucks say I know I have had one up just
yeah yeah he one up everybody on this
[ __ ] right this advant seven you would
buy that
no how about seven dollars ever I mean I
go yes seven dollars maybe that lies
Ivan da light seven I was in the seat
cushion all I said I'll never get us
both on here [ __ ] $30.00 reason why I
gotta had seven I mean 43 is because I
was doing the Junior Nationals in
Chicago in 2005 I had I was working as a
retail manager at a Bally Total Fitness
in Denver Colorado you know where the
Galleria I used to work there sir
yeah so I worked right there yeah
serving up shakes and [ __ ] took time off
to go have someone else run the store
had to buy had to pay for my own hotel
my own flight and barely had any money
for food and luckily enough one of my
old teammates happened to be there on
business and he got my room upgraded so
I can have a microfridge in my room and
I'm like [ __ ] man I don't have enough
money to go get a [ __ ] tan so what my
friends tan me up that was crap some
lady gave me a free tan at the show and
was like who the [ __ ] did your channels
like I did she's like this is [ __ ]
horrible but no snitching to me because
you you were trying to get make a living
in bodybuilding
Yeah right well you know I mean like
with it with no money with a real
education I would have been like Phil
Phil Phil hoho fellow everybody's you
can't you're not what are you doing but
you want to make money being a body
matter anything that like acting
fighting NFL MBA everyone has a story
yeah every city every success story
everyone told me not to do it imagine if
you didn't listen to it oh man and I
didn't listen to it because I remember
being in my hotel room and at that time
I had already done a photo shoot
in fortune at Mila's archers old gym for
flex magazine and they were impressed
and before the Junior Nationals I was
being pursued by Joe Weider you know
with like 90 Muslim fitness and also
muscular development they were going
through like a bidding war but I didn't
sign anything until after I'd done the
Junior Nationals after the prejudging I
end up getting a I didn't have enough
money for lunch and flex wheeler bought
me my lunch and then after that show was
over I did end up signing a two-year
deal with American media good money i
five grand a month at the time
that's ballin yeah but that time just
for being in just for you know being on
a magazine well I thought that was cool
a nightly now was without a supplement
sponsor yes I'm a prescriber guys like
that yeah when did you realize that you
put on muscle easily [ __ ] when I was
probably 13 okay when you know Here I am
doing a sum is K tournament doing
martial arts and Cotton's and [ __ ] and
then I'm doing push-ups and this guy's
looking at me like damn in like you're
like hey man like I wish I had that and
I'm like I didn't understand because
everybody on my block in Seattle was
ripped it is my genetic free swag route
so I was actually smallest the smallest
guy so as I got into high school track
and stuff like that you know you're
wearing no short shorts and [ __ ] and
people would just be able to see the
development and economic and never you
where you only got like I would we had
guys on my football team in college
where they literally couldn't lift
weights weeks or no they get too big
like you put on muscles so easily that
had like a mini here no swap for a day
list yeah when I moved to but not why
would that be bad just bulk up too much
UGA don't want that so yeah I when I
moved to Colorado go to you you know you
get the freshman 15 right away I got
freshman 20 but it wasn't fat well
muscled and then they're looking at me
like you know I graduated high school at
155 160 got to you my freshman year was
175 180 as a freshman
still you know I'm like you said I was
when they'll Dunkin I'll do all this
other cool stuff you know and yeah my
list for good you know it's a freshman
no lifting experience in high school
whatsoever because of that whole back
then
in the 90s but you got your growth yet
right especially with a sport basketball
tonight you could not only unworked out
no one lifted David Robinson was like
the one the main guy yeah so like back
then you know I tested because in
college you test in and then you test
out so you test in so freshmen tested in
I am I squatted 355 for a double and as
a freshman and then i benchpress 290 and
I thought no no no no crashing I did 245
for a single and I was 160 and at the
end of that freshman I was 290 and and
then by the time you were senior by the
time I was singer I mean we didn't even
test out because I was like why I
literally was still listening though
yeah as a senior in college you know
after you know
yeah because as soon as I got done
playing I mean I was already benching
three plays for that so I was able to do
that my my [ __ ] I wish somebody told
me this is a kid cuz I used to think as
a kid I'd be like well if I just lift
I'll do some bench by the summer I'll
look like that guy and my this wonderful
guy Lou Parata who was a strong man I
was a body builder mr. USA or whatever
back in the seventies and he was
training me and I had I was going to do
due date I was gonna play Danny McBride
part and Todd Phillips said I want you
to get muscular like he had a look kind
of tough so this is when I'm in my what
forties thing and I have four years ago
yeah a little bit a little bit more but
yes like Emily's so I go to Lou and I go
Asuna if I go dude I want to prom I got
a problem like 15 pounds of muscle and
who's an old-time body but looked medius
you do he goes how high do I go got
about two months okay and he looked at
me he goes okay so how do you he just
was tumor how do you expect dude I go
well I mean obviously I'll up my
calories and then we'll just lift heavy
and he goes yeah here's the you then
expect them to you you're genetically a
coat hanger okay and and the only way
I'm going to put that kind of weight on
you is if I change your endocrine system
if you want to go through that and we
have you know that you lay a full-time
[ __ ] job that's not even worth it but
you know that I just it was oh it was as
silly as it sounds it was I was so naive
it was an odd
you push at that age though it'd be
tough if you're younger yeah my body
type I don't know right you could yeah
you pick up this so hard you guys can do
I get these so let's go P mother let's
go P Lulu's not P my pants I cannot take
it run
I look it up glad buddy they said let's
go P we can go P we want to do a group P
let's go Group B I don't give a [ __ ]
groupie come on we're back from a P and
that and still notice my my war wound I
got a war wound from yesterday
yeah did the fight companion with Rogan
and here's the problem what happened
what is what I came in Allah won't
apologize all the people that go to
Irvine to see you into is it to eat and
in June 8th 9th and 10th friends that's
I'm still your manager for it now listen
it's not herpes it's not herpes
it war wounds war root well it's not
really a war wound can't say I'm um well
yeah well I show you right now you're
right it's not I might owe you but it is
it's a bully who got dealt with okay so
you're the bully okay so I were in it I
will admit that here's what happened I I
had I took two alpha brain I've never
taken it before and I just I don't you
ever taking that [ __ ] to nootropics okay
I don't know it did something to me and
I had two strong espressos now I was
also feeling good I was going to do a
fight companion with Joe Rogan and and
Brendan Schaub and I don't know what
happened maybe I got a surge of
testosterone the day before I done a lot
of [ __ ] deadlift still you know what
that's about
so so there I am with a heavy dick and
my legs my ass are feeling very [ __ ]
strong and grounded now now I I will
admit this I I will admit this I see I
see big brown he's all [ __ ] done up
he's all shiny and done up which is
already annoying me and I just figured
you know what I feel [ __ ] strong okay
now I'm gonna end in a roughhouse a
little bit and push him around a little
bit
you said yelling roughhouse Sunday it
was all you have redundant I'm saying
it's roughhouse Sunday came in grabbed
him by the hips and he turned his body
go stop and I go come on man Wilson back
don't want to roughhouse
then I poked him I grab his tits grab
his tits and I pushed him into the
fridge and he goes hey stop and I go I'm
still baby we'll be still and then I
think I took of the the end
my fingers and I and I brought him
against his face so I said oh no and
then he kind of he got he kind of
grabbed me a little and then I went back
I paint brushed him I went back with my
back hand give me a bachelor No okay so
I have this clown a big yeah dad I call
the Tom Sawyer I hit him yep don't
embarrass evening national money money I
just wanted a [ __ ] I was just poking
a bear days I just I just felt like
poking the bear because I had alpha
Brandon from some [ __ ] caffeine and
all of a sudden I see his face changed a
little bit and he goes alright and I go
huh
and I see him take his watch a gold
medal and preach in equality I can't
really I immediately sobered up I
immediately sobered up cuz I was clearly
drunk with some caffeine power home on
him and I went I went no I don't want to
any video though he goes I just here we
go it's too late and he began to close
this and tonight but didn't you grab oh
yes he could have Rogen's I held I
didn't know it all I grabbed no I run
around the world tried to hit me with
I'm trying to hit him with the pool cue
because I'm trying to keep him away now
now he's a bear and poke he's not gonna
do much because he I noticed he's simply
not afraid he's treating my swings like
they're like I'm like a gnat's in here
that didn't work for some anymore for
the guy and that was it's a goal movie
no oh no he's a close addition I'm like
oh this this book you ain't gonna do
[ __ ] then you decide to run you know I
can change I can change ran around the
pool thing I'm not around he's closing
distance oh I start to lose my foreskin
and we actually hosted this oh he
catches me oh hold of them now I'm I
don't know if you know this but I'm I'm
an experienced grappler not really
so he gets hold of me and I try to cover
up on my neck and then he proceeds to do
some terrible things to me he just
deceives to go through some moves one is
like choke me in a weird position where
my neck feels gonna break then he stops
and then he rolled into a flying camera
my head just just grind like like this
and I could feel the skin come off my
head I was
that's awesome I'm 50 with no skin on my
head thank you for the scalping thank
you for the Sunday [ __ ] scalping and
then he he rolls into an ankle lock and
begins to put pressure on my ankle what
you realize is that a trained fighter of
250 pounds can do whatever he wants bend
your bracelet my favorite part is though
we go through our embroidered laughs
through another breath we're sitting the
rodeos while she goes the funky I've
been doing I just in branded Sunday
beautiful days and Rosalia crazy and
then Jamie goes yeah they grabbed your
pool cue he saw the video and he goes
yeah Jamie goes look I gotta here and
Rome goes here Oh why are you use my
[ __ ] pool if you reach out cuz it
without handmade you can't get it it's
worth thousands of dollars needs like
dude what are you doing and he got
really mad at me and I finally had told
him I was like hey I was lying as I
relax it's just a pool cue okay groans
it's not that's my [ __ ] man you know
what you gotta copy good you can't even
replace that I was going yep run you
can't replay we had to calm him down and
at law all here they're left all the
guns were pointing at you yeah thank you
you're up here I'm feeling extra froggy
good [ __ ] with filthy and pop your head
like y'all get out you're good of an
athlete
no more coconut bear oh man do some
current events yeah you're a [ __ ]
bully
well vine again it's not herpes it's not
SARS you just it's a rug burn yeah we
got the party my brother lost part of
they were looking at me going what is
that I was like it's don't act like it's
a disease so I just I just got a little
scalping yeah somebody helping it's good
for you yeah good story you're good at
jujitsu buddy strong kid skill compared
to you on boys Gracie yes well it's why
it's what I do
Jamie Maya well you I thought I wouldn't
when I watched how easy it was to do it
I know he did this to five guys in a
room because I can tap everybody in this
room out and fight in less than a minute
which he did and people don't understand
that and then I thought to myself he's
200 pound guy I was like what would
happen if a toll 800 pound 900 pound
bear got ahold here was you were
literally thinking about that it's
pretty here's the other you know here's
the other thing I was thinking about
though that maybe I was like for me to
be that dominated by man is a little
disconcerting I could
[ __ ] but every [ __ ] UFC fighter you
could equip that I could have [ __ ] you
on camera and you could have done
nothing about it don't don't like I got
nothing for you on Instagram when Irvine
come see Bryan Callen
yeah June whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah
his ass holding me sore getting into you
and pathetic son and I'm like here's
your man yeah you know let me ask you
this would you do it while I was still
conscious of where you squeeze me until
I was unconscious I would come to
knowledge with conscience not what I
hear you squeal
it really was Kim's daughter I'd fight
I'd [ __ ] be poking at your eyes the
[ __ ] you gonna do that should take your
to him working with my mom she'll sink
what pit row I guess I'd have to I guess
I have to just yeah did I write a
[ __ ] enjoy we just have to take it
you got a real lack of being scared we
didn't talk about this so I got a new
dog oh yeah oh yeah I'm out you have
dogs right you ever know oh you know I'm
talking about random Java police dogs
like a real police dog now all from this
like world class to high-grade Malinois
free training I think it's called off
leash what Nick is but he's the trainer
okay so what he does using the secret
service for 15 or 20 years and he
trained dogs specifically for missions
stuff like that for the government the
high-level dude so he's doing that and
realized that he can you know make a
living training these dogs he has a
special five days and five days I'll
talk calculus treated like John Jones
Miesha Tate michael johnson tenor so we
we run the similar circles everywhere
tell me how great he is so I'm looking
for a dog and I was originally looking
for a German Shepherd or something else
and he goes man this is gonna sound a
little ridiculous you know dogs but this
lady like oh I've been working with for
the last 20 years she has a Malinois
that could be perfect as a family dog
yields
Tim he lives in I think it was in
Connecticut or DC I forget and he goes
it's a one in a thousand chance that
should be a fit
I'm a flat to LA just to make sure that
this dog is as good she says Iran so he
goes there so she takes like it's pretty
freakin great man so I Drive up there
last night and it's I forget where it's
at but fight an hour for me not too bad
and they have this whole state there and
I'd out the car and I'm thinking there's
gonna be Malinois German Shepherds
actually there's this turkey is a
[ __ ] giant turkey mitt Merc turkey
don't lie to me you guys I miss your
drinking person you see I don't taste my
turkey EDL China Sea or oh yeah take
mine not for long yeah but we're at the
beak at the beak he's coming up to your
role after dinner [ __ ] turd it was a
dinosaur huh it was a step I will
terrify mini average if any Austin how
much for the turkey
that's a juicer that thing's out for
sale oh no no Turk apologize to my house
and that [ __ ] turkeys up my friend
door huh ain't nobody come to know man
on your name IP come on Alan nutsack
taking off its video that says this
thing with seven below what's called
it's called it's called amateur Tom I
would owe you dinner Tom I will never
eat turkey again I've seen that the
thing was hideous yeah I will never talk
about a wild turkey but it was dark
this means yeah I'm scared it's big
liver elbow no but you know what you
speak wisdom because when you if you
were to have an ostrich if you would
have if you would have a couple of big
turkeys and even peacocks
they are territorial and they'll come
after an intruder so see what she'll see
as all these they don't sell to
civilians the dogs each other were
police training military dogs gonna
inhale on attacker for sure so I know it
oh do they [ __ ] with the turkey juice oh
no no again how much for the turkey but
it's when it went in part with the heard
about try the turkey one apart with the
turkey that kind of I don't see a turkey
in person I was to deal with the German
Shepherd sewers she's strictly Malinois
girl
mal wahoo is that the yeah that's a
thing those Bo Campion bloodlines she
gets them from Belgium had some of those
bad boys turned on me in Afghanistan
put me put me in a bite suit without a
helmet I want what about mouth they
won't bite your head I go excuse me sir
can you get into that meeting no no guys
just run just run I go I know but I
don't have a [ __ ] I got our video I
don't have a helmet is by me and my men
Mac here's an area here back my neck
here now it about this guy
no we're bad is it be fine you just run
is it a a bite you in an arm I go I know
you can't get into his brain it's
[ __ ] really cool I have any padding
and back my vehicle Sudan be heard ed -
yeah y'all got a hold of subs
he had a glove on but it crushes him and
he starts screaming get this wolf to
[ __ ] off me get the wolf off me don't do
it on Sunday let's figure out dogma dude
I'd like to come out watch that every
flood they were showing videos is Johnny
to tag by smell more impressive they'll
know they'll get get onto you with their
back teeth this guy it is Nick from
Mombasa off leash training off leash
canine training Ulis called off he's
doing five days five days your dog's
[ __ ] neck
Nick I got a corgi I got a beautiful
Shepherd I'll do whatever it takes for
you to take my dogs hey little baby hey
man you're a [ __ ] hot Mick to
yourself Nick are you not not that level
yet Phil I got a guy for you hey you if
your show got picked up you might have
done it I'm on the Goldbergs celebrity
[ __ ] is going on man
why did you he didn't even you need to
have a dog exactly it's like needs one
yeah look man I'm so I have serious dog
in me I want myself mal one I should I'm
pretty crunk about it let's go to Oscar
night uh Nita Nita you get out there did
they name this thing in Belgium I can't
[ __ ] name it which I hate it nothing
I need it yeah my dog's name is Nico a
little [ __ ] you know what the like
name some day my daughter named my
German Shepherd so a little bit more
masculine
yeah I'm it's a female dog I just know I
like myself living you know when kids
name darling my daughter's like I want
to name the dog Bashi and I'm like I'm
not gonna Bashi badging I'd like
something cool like lip they're wearing
to crush your spirit I what was that
dimepiece uh shredded girl we're talking
about
Osumi i'd like hey me SHINee SHINee
I'd like me money call her nique [ __ ]
Nika hey hey Myka get you leeks pretty
does she sell me [ __ ] yeah yeah Nico
Nick my dog's name is Nico don't bite my
[ __ ] style
well Malaga he goes mcore ki look
anyways I should [ __ ] art I didn't
yell more you this this gardener this
guy is from Mexican guy goes he looks
like I live like a Robin Robin
by one I don't see Sir Robin arrived
before jump around like a robber you
know just a mighty my kid want a dog
right now how much where I can find dog
like that I was like well I don't know
it's [ __ ] shut already hold a given a
body in here rabbit is +1 aw hey what
made you pick the Corgi though your kid
yeah I didn't yeah I wiped my wife from
my daughter victim is a lot of mail I
got a female Shepard that's a plea so if
I wanted a male someone to Shepherds
[ __ ] yeah instead you got the [ __ ] up
don't why I want a male Shepard I want
Nick you're seeing a 45 days that thing
will do calligraphy what by the time
this guy someone else gonna speak two
languages I just want to get back pretty
excited about it
Wow oh man Oh woody gotcha all right the
first one is Tiger Woods got picked up
this morning oh he does he like please
buddy [ __ ] I did like everything I'll
see ya boy oh boy oh boy he looks tired
and his eyes aren't red no but you can
see the body the what tamarkan that
whether or not alcohol possibly it could
be some other drug medications I mean
like that yeah uh real quick seat in the
correct me if I'm wrong here fella see
he has two good things don't phone he's
I think his mom was Korean and his dad's
black nut I'm honest hi Oh his mother
dad was Native American and white and
black she had a lot of he probably got
and dad was super dark and his mom was a
lot that wasn't dark buddy instead was a
moms are the Mamas was way more debris
up his parents yeah but either way
usually if you're black and Asian you
age [ __ ] like a fine wine yeah he's
had some stress he's like yeah his dad's
dogged yeah is that is that Muhammad Ali
yes pretty sorry
I knew Browns life that's why these guys
like that so let's see I could fit right
yeah now I knew that's why I want to
bring up but so his dad's dark but
usually when you're like dark complexion
with especially Asian or black they it's
hard to tell someone's age yeah however
the he looks 100 years old and that DUI
pick yeah find out what is his total
nationalities a Thai Native American
black his mom looked like highly she's a
hunter percent i wow so she's completely
Thailand
that's pretty cool she's got a because
it looks just awful
these two have the rough go kind of I
mean is it a rough go though he has a
shitload of money got pulled over who
knows what he'll I feel you know I feel
about that he was he was totally perfect
his whole life and had to be from the
age of three right it's pretty done and
then all of a sudden he's got these that
that dedication like I know people who
know him I know his right I don't well
death talk Asian black American Indian
Asian actor that's a cool car no no
Tiger refers to his makeup as so
Caucasian black American Indian Asian
okay what is this what is this a Kerala
Nation I'm Evelyn Kaplan Asian yak
abalone either way his daddy was like a
monk like he trained so hard he would go
to bed early in all that say was the
other side show a child didn't damn golf
club yeah all somehow he goes dog will
come out and come at him he gets found
out you know he's got this beautiful
wife is not an offic bah-bah-bah but I
felt like I really like in a way I think
if he had if I had could have gotten his
ear I would have said hey Tiger just
please get up and just go hey everybody
I [ __ ] up I'm going to try to be
better I've never had to deal with this
kind of [ __ ] before I have the
best-looking women in the world throwing
themselves at me and I'm a human being
and just don't even read from his grave
you know you know how we gotta hell I
got to learn that sex ring do you guys
know how no oh yeah Michael Jordan
achill Jordan
that's right here is that true you
started hanging out with like the elite
elite of sport yeah and they're like I
said every moment with no bro I know you
got you know
well it might come as a surprise but
elite athletes I've seen I've seen some
of this in person elite athletes like
those guys the women like them women I
don't know that I love my belly by like
Ferraris Lamborghinis what'd I say
I'm Tiger Woods the problem the problem
with that is you're right and my girl
and I were talking about actually this
morning is that English I should jump
well know what he should have done is
exactly what you just said just come out
with it before the news does and even
with him getting pulled over everybody's
gonna have an opinion saying like oh he
should have caught an uber he should
have did this she's like look man my
career is not where it want to be you
know I've dealt with these back
surgeries this net I got every Tom Dick
and Harry trying to critique my [ __ ]
legacy I had this scandal and [ __ ] like
just you know a little weed got behind
the wheel ice does is as stupid as I
could be my hairs leaders how stupid as
I am to us yeah yeah just talk just say
this is what I'd done and I think
nowadays when we start to see these the
fakeness yeah just be real just be like
dude when people say that I got [ __ ]
pulled over you know and yeah that
sucked because I do live here and that
gatekeeper probably snitched on me or
whatever but you know what I had a
little bit too many didn't think I had
too many and it was time for me to get
my ass home cuz I should to do yeah and
you know what my dog Alexa and a cop got
lined up and I messed up I take
accountability for my actions I'm
already here I'm not going to do some
PSA about it all I'm going to say is
that I'm a human being I've made a total
ass of myself I embarrass myself and my
family and you know it to my fans I'm
sorry to those people that mad I'm sorry
yeah you know I remember back you're
just you're just real man again so much
for like us then have been having your
your PR person deal with it or reading
something or being like I got on your
damn Instagram right there that went
live and said guys I just got [ __ ]
pulled over I am a piece of [ __ ] I
should not I was ambitious I just like
yo I would have smoked because they say
it's not for alcohol no I think four
different medications be but they don't
know because that's but he could
literally just tweet out whatever I
glitter on Snapple are you're gonna see
in the morning I had whatever I took
some pills I don't even [ __ ] me it might
question your even no anyway yeah gonna
say some real quick so the week from put
myself out to the week of my college
graduation I went out to the Stampede
classics I invited em to Calgary okay
and Jennifer and did I have too many
maybe I don't know all I do know is that
I did get pulled over I got a car and he
asked me a question you've been drinking
and I said yes sir he says how many I
said I'm not gonna act like I counted
but I do know when I stopped he goes
well how do you know when you stop I
said because that was when they stopped
serving free liquor to the girls and I
was having girls look me up yeah he said
okay get out hard in the N word and I
said well I'm going to deny breathalyzer
but I will do a roadside I did it's not
a white cop
yep got to pull the racial flag I would
no I just I talked the racial bomb I
didn't even have to I just went ahead
and said I'm a student I'm graduating
from college my family's in town and
this and then I don't say like I'm drunk
but I'll do a roadside did the roadside
pass he said okay where do you live I
lied told him that I gave him one of my
teammates his houses which was like
three blocks away and I said hey if you
follow me and I'm doing something stupid
hey take my eyes of jail that's why I
said to him yeah but I pass the roadside
victimize he maybe walk and do stupid
alphabet and also the shits and until
you read and know anything that's out of
way just got away yeah they're telling
about like wait you're right you just
well why didn't he just say hey man I
did this it's saying that he hire woods
so the cop wants to be the guy who
caught Tiger Woods but it says that
worked at that point was became arrogant
all he had to say is is that you know
what man
like yeah I had a few I had this that
now that you smell alcohol my breath how
about I just do a roadside we can get
out of here unless you're wasted unless
if you're yeah drunk he was here too but
you can't bounce back from this like Mel
gear see Mel Gibson else want a off any
bounce back that's right house house
back Elmo can't miss I know makes the
best movie late Blacks and Jews and you
know shows 10 ah he was drunk he was
jumped in the stoppages what's up sugar
tip I thought it was I watch every movie
comes out with is you have waited you
never seen the funeral topicals of sugar
10 no [ __ ] you my warious I mean yeah I
think that sometimes there's something
really powerful about when people my
friend [ __ ] up my friend Rackham today
had had fooled around with a friend of
ours girl he was drunk and he just did
it and we were ready to we were just
like dude that's a scumbag where we were
all going bad on and he came in and he
looked at us and he goes I [ __ ] up
guys I [ __ ] up that's all I know say I
just got weak and I don't know what to
do he started cry so I tried to get like
I know we're all I call here all like
this well he was so sorry but he just
said I [ __ ] up I thought I was
stronger and I just I'm weak hold on he
[ __ ] your buddy girl
yeah and and that was what I interpreter
stop that I we're about to yeah acted
out the way now the way he did it though
the way he did he
so sorry and he was so weak and he goes
she's so hot and I [ __ ] knew I was
doing the wrong thing and I did it
anyway and I felt like a piece of [ __ ]
and I and I'm sorry and I wouldn't even
told you guys I would try to get away
with it but I got caught and now I feel
like the worst person will and he was so
sorry and so sincere and he kept saying
I [ __ ] up and he's trying not to cry
we were all like wow you know what
you're so [ __ ] sincere and you are so
sorry
and we [ __ ] get it we knew he was a
good guy he just said I got weak she's
so [ __ ] hot and I'm a PC Idol
different inflection but Miguel I can't
even my buddy we like weekend and I
holdover if he had one if I put your
girl's still I don't care about Dylan
after any wars no AI in the more where
there's a loyalty on I don't exactly get
her dress anyway I get it believe me I
get it but he worked his way back in
what gifts that's not beautiful if he
was like I'll do whatever I got to do
I'm a piece of [ __ ] and my man how old
are you he was dry we were like 22 oh
and you're that yeah based on officer -
I'm a grown-ass man like that every time
grown do the young Khalid Sheikh shift
on account you probably [ __ ] the bump
around - well that is didn't tell that
was it now you're what should be I mean
it's lemming there's just something
about it you really have anywhere else
to go
I mean as our boy Tom Morello says you
know even rock bottom has a little
wiggle room he's [ __ ] okay like hey
he's there but what is what is he doing
now is he is he playing is he is he is
active he would I got injured again yeah
I think he's just doing it because it
feels like you have to get more money
than God right just for what I want to
do right and here's the thing with
tighter man and I hate to say this but
here's though yeah this is fun but no I
heard that definitely some bad stuff in
your life if god those chilis you're
here then I'm read mark Rendon yours not
to flow it's not gonna get grow my [ __ ]
I look at the huge he lives near here
lined up come on man let me not terrible
I'm terrible in here by rate and look
hey do you know off do you may say this
is oh I mean it's just running from him
yeah
do you think that like do you think that
when he had that issue with his ex-wife
that by him the way he handled it
mishandled is the problem you know I've
been I think my thighs his powers or his
mojo it just went like your soul
everything you know handle it right he
didn't handle it right then fan and he
tried to he I all week to seem out the
Taylor is the Edison endeavour all Hill
to [ __ ] any losses mojo for sure but I
imagine imagine golf like football would
like yep or like this she came out with
LeBron James you think he's still not
going to ball out
well I'm event it don't be on different
sport also yes it is and it also depends
more medicine it is and I also think
though it depends on kind of like the
the image the image that you have
attached yourself to right now so he had
an image of perfection and when that was
shattered and he had really a long time
his chameleon Isaac villain yeah okay
what else ain't helping the lazy [ __ ]
chameleon eyes you can see his lights
isn't you cloudy the white 17 days his
hair is so awful yeah you know then the
[ __ ] shirt is all ring you can see
the whites under his eyeballs like so
the pupils there's is that that he
looked tired he looks like the most
depressed man the world as he does for
someone that has a gazillion dollars
it's really crazy money can't buy
happiness does both Lee I mean but you
can't buy here either
well rented yeah that's true doll trucks
it can not care if you get a hair
transplant then why wouldn't he do which
I've had because he's got a gazillion
dollars he don't give a [ __ ] I had one
day I had a hair but really 10 years ago
things good [ __ ] got money you know
Carrie is like this what else gotcha
I've looked and there's nowhere else for
him the guy linking gives a [ __ ] about
golf
he's probably boning a million girls I
do you think he went back to doing that
again yeah my mind no team to I also
don't you stop now I think yeah worse
now there's no repercussions only in the
world not to give a [ __ ] about golf we
all know your dirtbag yeah yeah we got
to lose talking watching the strip club
girls like oh hell yeah before like I
don't know it's on now it's on now God
what else you got - I don't know I'm
losing the [ __ ] up never [ __ ] I don't
know someone's you let me this I already
has a piece to fix on 0 Mexico
girl from a very specific place in
Mexico she Rani ultramarathon of won
first place we rinse in my sandals a
skirt and a scarf that I should be
educated be fat shame that's a Mexican
[ __ ] no professional training nothing no
that's that area those are those areas
where that like like we're born to run
they were talking about where name is
Kenny the rules one like your areas
where those already won my Ultimates on
win sandal got a lot of Native American
and we get yellow an Aztec inner we get
the other girls they help although [ __ ]
on so the if you're a sponsor to the
other girls you just drop them right now
probably jump on this girls train that
might write them down but there is there
are groups of people in those areas that
have crazy it's like the Kenyans like
way up in the highlands they've just got
a crazy ability to run forever - like
it's a tandem Sandro in sand recycled
sandals in from made from tires
dude get water left my girls from axel
apart two of my heart that even close to
Guadalajara she's brother she is she has
got a lot of Nader can Hamada that's a
lot of indigenous Native America Aztec
maybe they're taking a movie after South
Amer kneeling saying oh yes is Wow
kudos to her Liam who what's that what's
that they got to complain my any [ __ ]
knee hurts they're like five million
people in a plateau in Kenya and they
just dominate they [ __ ] dominate the
EB I mean one guy who with a farmer and
in one year he held a world record he
was like my friends running he was
driving a cab he goes I'm gonna run like
that I mean it in your later world
champion thank you if Iceland did a
piece there where you saw them you see
those two Brit like IRAs yeah show - oh
yeah white boys let's go live with him
trailer them yep Wow and they're doing
well now yeah you know she got Jim to
him alright the next one has a crowd a
Power Ranger guy did you guys hear about
this at the Phoenix Comic Con he had
this guy oh no that guy who had like a
bunch of weapons on including throwing
stars some loaded guns and he was out
there to kill the Green Ranger is that
like Tom McCullar on the [ __ ] into the
Comic Cons into a side door then some
girl was communicating with him on
Facebook or something and she told the
least like this guy's kind of crazy he's
obviously least got him God he had
thrown water in his Boulder only stages
you know he called himself The Punisher
- yeah oh you thought I wanted to
realize common good
yeah he's not obviously not well and he
needs to be in a hospital out of me
right away good and put him down and he
probably Keys got that's a big face he
was carrying 2:45 that's so nice force
it in his face in his job he's got a
pouch under a 12-gauge shotgun a combat
knife pepper spray and throwing stars
all in all just in case a bee has to go
Brian counted okay listen I carry funny
stars at all times
that guy is that's so intense man by the
way take a look at Lynda Carter down
there please now is at this premiere and
I was standing right next to this gal
that's when the Carter 65 please take
her in for a second please understand
that's what she looks like in real
[ __ ] life staying on the right I'm
talking about the right brother well
that's Lynda Carter at 65 didn't
wha-what-what say anything what Jillian
everybody 65 does I'm Ella
now you out of your [ __ ] you know
what you seen share at seven do you have
some [ __ ] you - you're a savvy respect
bro brothers you look 65 bro no she kept
anybody she'll 65 what guys
look at her she's a kissy sorry she look
good though man I mean I ain't gonna
hate no I mean I'm bad at it when I let
it go guys are a couple haters huh no
I'm not glad this is the hate podcast
she's just a mom like mom that's a
grandma son she called me on 37 my mom
66 a man label is hot gas again we hate
women who [ __ ] preserve himself no
she looks great
I'm out remind us you'll shoot my girl
right there that's my girl I would date
her right now my wife was I Brian stop
dating Lynda Carter I go no I can see
her oh you look at share at 17 that
that's where that'll blow your mind when
you call so now like that they better
not look 65 you know seriesindi
gentleman 65 I was standing next to her
she looks amazing that picture Sheila
capability you are wrong sir you have
been a little agree don't talk about if
you talk about my girl like that again
I'm gonna get mad and we're gonna for if
she blows it
I'll start poking the bear now let me
take a look at her at 6:00 - yeah that's
yeah she's
and uh oh you don't think oh no think
that grandma from one woman ten don't
call her a grandma from wonder well
nothing she said car Wonder Woman done
don't say that I'm gonna make I'm gonna
get mad she's 70 that's TC 70 yeah she
looks tight and laughs and seventy seven
seventy yeah I mean compared to your
girl though no my girl header had the
posture of a [ __ ] Michigan Shanna
shoes like this [ __ ] on the way now
you're being silly on your compact in
seven my fists are getting [ __ ]
boring though you should do so I miss
our boy [ __ ] up those side you here I
would love your whose I'm going to be
honest with you right now look at me
I'll fight you for Lynda Carter right
now and I'll take another Russian gal
pay and you know what I'll do I will rip
the hair off the top of your head plus
with me again I will rip the top your
hero
actually that's right it's something I
can't I can't [ __ ] with our next revenge
it I gotta keep my mouth shut down
that's knocked out that you ain't read
me the reason right there and so
Waterman
I'd write let no man right awesome
scalping that's [ __ ] so a water park
opened up their their grand opening
appeals this weekend and they had to
shut down three slides
cuz this happened to the little kids a
kickin me okay though he's fine yeah
slashes bow oh ooooh outside try good
your biggest fear ever ahead like what's
the worst that could happen
oh we could fall off nah no one does
that see you down there okay me quedo
they're so fast he's lucky that it was
right there that's called inertia look
at his body I think amazing
that was like some Tony Hawk [ __ ] but
first up you see on a skateboard you got
my don't [ __ ] with water park that's
gonna leave in water carts give me more
than you never when you want a row yeah
you can catch I love your one South
Shore
water world South shorts close now but
then at you at Six Flags and in where
Alicia's used to be they have a water
park and me the sea football team went
there and they have those big wrasse I'm
a big thing you flip it diggin it dude
the guy we go up through go hey man are
we to overweight the guy goes now I know
it says to counter pounds but I've seen
bigger dudes and you do it we get up
there we I so close to the death I've
ever I
turn it was going hang off good work
howdy boys up there it's going oh and
everyone I've grown and clock me we're
gonna die rolled off and I wanted to
hang a whole life yeah well it's closer
because there's one with it's really fat
guy and they're called him Gordo call
him fatty and he goes flying you gotta
bring it up he luck he goes down and
just goes there laughing sorry cuz he
goes I just honest base first me just
goes in yeah
does your merit is there as well right
there there's done oh hey watch it watch
it
oh god I'm like missing no meals
oh god no now watch this [ __ ]
everybody's be oh god ugh
they're like you sure you wanna do this
[ __ ] man remember death down there brah
oh he's [ __ ] my head first your tits
first Mexican he's not afraid of [ __ ]
watch this watch this honey Hey oh ho
great [ __ ] monk there's nothing it's
not worth it oh yeah I am telling you
man there's a reason why don't little
water world anymore and I like that and
everybody said oh go on a speech like
hell no I ever doing that stuff I've
laughed I think it's because of the
Karma that I'm afraid to have because
I've laughed too many times that videos
like this and that guy's just bring that
up for [ __ ] or belated handle for a
second which another fat guys on
waterslide someone down there and so I
see what I don't watch screaming me well
this is it laughing here lean that one
that's what that won't have this stupid
music this music is awful look at this
Jimmy is it oh no
what's a slip and slide he connected he
just goes you know what's probably stop
stop yeah yeah that was a nice try to
date have you watchin this one Brandon
Vera kicked out Angela Ghana from
Alliance Wow I thought her talking brain
any mere kicks worthless trifling he
made a human out of Alliant oh I'm sorry
I know what's going on with this house
you got to give me some backstory on
this one so angela is the girl who at
the UFC athletes retreat she would go on
social me and post pictures of cyborg
talking [ __ ] about her cyborg the female
it literally cyber bullying her
cyborg Caesar athletes retreat addresses
her punches soccer in the face for
talking [ __ ] about it so then this idiot
angela is po is gonna sue her she's
suing cyborg but now she's even going on
social media more like just kind of
taunting cyborg and Brandon Vera is a
great dude and like I can't have this at
my gym I guess I'm a gym she starts
drama she's a troublemaker
so he's like you're out yeah good for
him because you don't need that type of
[ __ ] in there there's no respect and
also yeah she also didn't get punched to
let the way cyborg can punch she got
that soft yeah that's all a bunch of the
punch but that's besides the fast yeah
didn't leave a mark at it is there any a
bunch of Jala yes she's been oh she got
punched be like Disney she's legit kappa
get knocked out she got [ __ ] up right
but brandenburg puts her i was going to
leave this alone but this trifling [ __ ]
is still at it she kind of embodies
what's wrong with the world today super
entitled whines and cries about
everything
IG ass famous i'm not matter ask uh and
no other skills whatsoever pretty
worthless [ __ ] you got your card pulled
for cyber bullying so when you thought
you'd never run to super drama queen do
me a favor keep us away from alliance uh
yeah and but he has a good point it's
true PS there's a reason why no one to
stand up for you got your homegirls
training partners even fighters at the
summit you deserved it which is true
also your hospital picks our ship for a
case that you went to Snoop Dogg concert
at the very same evening it was a good
point a you know good for him he's a
really good dude yeah you know it like
that is a no-bullshit time again that
goes to show that look we live in this
world of heavy cyberbullying and no one
ever gets called out and you both know
that this goes on and witness just be
great to like just run up on that person
one damage there's no consequence right
so then when being widowed so you can't
you can't advocate so we inputted this a
sneak a no yeah because I
talks about cyborgs mana also they're
fighters and if you're going to do that
and get in cyberspace after you post
that really mean [ __ ] you're an in your
five professional fighter you can get
out fine we're seven Deonte Walter this
guy kept around yeah the answer was to
come to the gym
here's that this dude shows up jumps in
the ring you Dante Walter do you have to
others get scams out let everyone know
he'll Kate this this win that mean
banging him out good knock him the [ __ ]
out good
that was another case in England where
the satisfying [ __ ] to this English
boxer huge posture somehow showing
Lisa's address showed up as doors like
what the [ __ ] up now and the guy was
like oh [ __ ] that's because these the
social - I feel like it needs to happen
like it's way more I get me I think
there needs to be I was actually
thinking about suspects as a Sri and I
we go through some of this crap and
people always tell all don't worry about
the haters in sight it's not hating it's
like you know you deal with racial
comments you deal with real bullying
garbage and it would be great to just
have a couple computer hackers at your
side to just say no no I got this guy's
IP address yeah I also know where he
works
yeah and you know first of all what I
would love to do is take what he wrote
or she wrote with the boss leg and head
and gave it to the bottom like this is
the type of piece of [ __ ] that you hire
or go to the kids the father's son's
school go to the superintendent or go to
the you know the teacher and say this is
some of those dad though the time it
balls made well if I see a troll and
click on a profile they have kids like
oh my god tell your kids you're hating
on a guy he's so much more successful
than your dad yeah go tell your kid what
you were doing and he's like holy [ __ ]
my dad's a loser why I've clown a few
guys like that and said you know it's
kind of weird that you're calling me
these names and this and that but you
have children you have a daughter you
have this that and the other go tell
your daughter hey I get a mean comment
to Phil he's yes every time it's a
linker they go oh my God my dad's a
[ __ ] loser real loser like real idiot
yeah so but yeah we're not horrible I
mean you know they find is that they did
the stage that it was like just kids in
the basement he's not know actually
people from its doctors lawyers it's
kindergarten teachers it's a subset of
the society there are just people out
there that are frustrated with their
life or they're angry or they just get
off on being anonymous and just being
mean it's just assess but it was most of
time it's in last
out like when I first are done stamp I
get all the time and then people I find
these guys are writing these horrible
comic things flying my dad's like man
I've always wanted to stand out like
dude I saw you post that horrible
comment so it's Tim lashing out because
you're chasing is just really accessible
and they've never you know they didn't
like you it's a huge issue but is if you
let it be an issue no but I'm saying
it's a huge issue not for me because I'm
still winning I'm still doing my thing
but it's an issue for them I'm saying
because they're one huge is just there
walking amongst us this is the issue
feel it even for be your kids go to high
school so when I was in hot in middle
school high school I got bullied
I like dealt with it when I went back to
school I talked in the face
there would be an altercation it get
squashed now kids get bullied in school
then they go home online bully then they
came up on them so that's why I see a
more braid of suicide to just saying the
bullying now is 24/7 and then and then
the parents are you let alone the
teachers unfortunately are just like
well you can't really do anything yes
you can eventually these kids are going
to take it in our own hand yeah and it
ain't just in the inner cities either
it's you know just everywhere I would
tell any kid like hey don't like if my
son daughter was getting punked like
this all the damn sign document you're
going to have a choice like you're going
to have a decision you have to make yeah
and it's like are you going to continue
to let this happen and if the kid keeps
running to the teacher they're made fun
of for that so now it just becomes a
bigger issue when really all these kids
are trying to do is just you know go get
an education or adults or just trying to
go to work and go do their 9 to 5 or 8
to 5 and just go live a life
unfortunately we deal with this way too
often I think it is unfortunate but in
this case I do see that you know justice
was served in them you know best of luck
to her but I'm a cyborg fan and I'm glad
that she speaks out about this though
because I'm tired of her getting the
runaround and people just you know
lashing out at her she's done really
nothing wrong but just do her crap I
want a high [ __ ] life they should
show some more respect and it works out
for me yeah I do too
well yeah Jim but this is what else is
weird so then I have to more of the
details but so you're telling me at the
UFC the same summit not the same stuff
before the week when they did the
pressure it's Kevin Lee and
Michael chisa jeiza jeiza chiesa get an
altercation on stage
Kaiser gets punched in the face by Kevin
Lee v OC does I you know they show that
highlight over and over and over and how
is that any different right what if it
happens again on your watch at a UFC
athlete retreat in cyber punch Saturday
and now we're talking about your
pressing charges
exactly but what but then what about
Kevin Lee how you guys down here left
there's no repercussions or how about
when John John the DC sold one of the
big babies all time but you know this
fight at a press conference mm-hmm where
we were the charges pressed then now
also inside were no timeout charges
pressed against that's crap and you
don't think you can help out you don't
think they know the LAPD you don't think
they can I'm sorry the Las Vegas PD you
don't think that they could sway them in
a direction or how we do that man I
don't know what they what the what is it
about cyborg she can't catch a break
that's yeah I think that's mama Ghana
though right so if she wants to be a
jerk and press charges no matter what
and you know what happened that it would
take dana white one text one hey stop
this knock it off and it oh [ __ ] her
pants yeah that's all hey stop this
[ __ ] or your Invicta for the next ten
years it's over games over
yeah no one to help see no one's helping
her no she's also career suicide she's
kicked out of her gym she's gonna get
booed like a [ __ ] if she ever
fights in UFC again your thus pitch you
know professor on fire that snitched on
another fighter that your cyber bullying
that everyone deals with just you need
to see all your thighs do you know me
UFC fighters would love that UFC fighter
doing it well you know how many UFC
fighters would love to sock when these
haters in the face and then cyborg
socks the girl in the face I hate to
tell you I keep forgetting a name I
don't even [ __ ] know I don't you
would magnet answer magnet that's what
she you're known as this girl you're the
snitch that shares a blood ass and I
appreciate that but you're a terrible
person yeah but look at these pictures
like this isn't this is [ __ ] she's
just highlighting all this stuff and
still talking [ __ ] is kind of [ __ ]
what else you got in um how about this
in Australia as usual woman a nine-foot
shark jumped into a fishing boat while
someone was actually fishing there and
it was a great white great white
he's like so much when he he was able to
jump on top of that top part of the boat
and I don't know if you actually let the
fish go if I just wait until he died
they have said he's struck to do is
pectoral fin as we jumped in my first
instinct was to say nine feet isn't that
big and now Mike that's my feet that is
our G that's a giant shark like an eight
20 feet it's but it's nine and seventy
three or anything so to drill them you
can't do you have video of that guy
petting the great white you seen that
once you pull that up for a sec pull
that up and take a look at this this
thing was curious and it was out of the
water and watch this [ __ ] pet
this great white have you seen it
Brennan uh yeah this one right there
yeah seven years ago it's old you hope
he'll take a look at this just watch oh
it's just fair at all it's just staring
okay oh now now that's a nine-footer
yeah I can't man enjoy that [ __ ] please
enjoy that [ __ ] the wing it it's like
kind of enjoying it like no this is not
serious it's kind of like I guess if
you're behind it with you well yes I
wrote on that it should I [ __ ] man you
can kind of dive into its mouth and I
wonder what what happened just like wait
wait ever do it on you just never to die
in dive in go ahead wait you out will
freak out or we all chomp down don't you
just leave you in there yeah I mean you
should some straight Jack Sparrow's yeah
let's try it sometimes you just
disappear
it's do you have any appearances you
want plug before we get out of here yeah
I'm actually going over to New York next
is actually this Saturday at the NPC
Atlantic States hosted by Olympia head
judge Steve Weinberger nice and then
after that just catch me over at
Armbrust getting after further you know
mr. Olympia run loving them for more
information for that just go on you know
my social media at Phil Heath I'm going
to be doing random posts from here and
they're talking about the Olympia well
I'm actually have to sign my olympia
contract as I get home on Monday so you
know they'll they'll be able to find out
more information about that and really
just you know I really appreciate it you
know appreciate it to all my fans out
there
shout out to the guys at the you
so they they have been doing some really
amazing stuff and we plan on doing more
work with them shout to my friend Robert
Irvine
he's along with the Gary Sinise
foundation been doing some really cool
stuff and I can't wait to see those guys
because we've been able to go on go on
tour you know saluting the troops and
whatnot but really that's all I got you
know thanks for having me on
yeah man we don't have support for a day
think about those people who gave their
lives and the families that are dealing
with that everybody thanks for listening
Phil Heath you're the man man we really
man hey come see me in Irvine mr.
Lindberg on June 8th 9th and 10th and
yes seven time in September ago see
Bryan Cal was it'd be September 8th 9th
another time sorry buddy June June a
lighted with I know June 8th 9th and
10th you can come touch my war wound T
Pat Buchanan's all tickets my scalping
next week I will be in Australia that's
crazy even say that I will be in
Australia the only tickets left are in
Auckland and the additional show in
Sydney and those are almost sold out t
fat cake calm for all those tickets then
June 22nd Gotham comedy club in New York
City I will be there some like a dot-com
this is a final kid with the gifted one
we're out